>>> ALLIES OF THE FORMER
PRESIDENT ARE NOW RESPONDING TO
PARTS OF THE MAR-A-LAGO SEARCH
AFFIDAVIT THAT WERE RELEASED.
HIS SPOKESPERSON RELEASED THIS,
THE RELEASE OF THE HEAVILY
REDACTED OVERTLY AFFIDAVIT SHOWS
THAT PRESIDENT BIDEN IS -- THIS
IS A GRAVE TRAVESTY AND WHAT IS
UNREDACTED ONLY FURTHER SUPPORTS
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S POSITION THAT
THERE WAS NO REASON FOR A RAID.
IT IS ALL POLITICS.
>> GABBY ORR JOINS US NOW AND
KIM AND PHIL ARE BACK WITH US.
WE HEARD THIS BEFORE, IT FEELS
LIKE WHEN THE TRUMP TEAM DOESN'T
LIKE BEING INVESTIGATED, THEY
SAY IT'S ALL POLITICS.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
THEY SEEM TO BE LEANING INTO HOW
MANY REDACTIONS WERE CONTAINED
IN THE VERSION OF THE AFFIDAVIT
THAT WAS UNSEALED THIS
AFTERNOON.
KIND OF A BIZARRE WAY TO
APPROACH THIS.
BOTH TRUMP AND HIS SPOKESPERSON
HAVE SAID ON SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORMS THAT THIS WAS A
HEAVILY REDACTED DOCUMENT.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME, THEY'RE
USING THE UNREDACTED PARTS, THE
PARTS MADE PUBLIC FOR US TO
REVIEW IN ORDER TO BUILD OUT
THEIR DEFENSE.
AS YOU SAID, IT'S VERY
POLITICAL.
I WANT TO READ YOU PART OF OF A
POST TO TRUTH SOCIAL THAT DONALD
TRUMP SHARED.
HE SAID AFFIDAVIT HEAVILY
REDACTED.
NOTHING MENTIONED ON NUCLEAR.
A TOTAL NUCLEAR SUBTRAFUGE BY
THE FBI AND DOJ.
THEY SAID THEY COOPERATED ALL
ALONG, BUT WE KNOW THAT ISN'T
THE CASE.
WE KNOW THAT IT TOOK MONTHS AND
MONTHS FOR TRUMP'S TEAM TO
FINALLY ALLOW NATIONAL ARCHIVES
TO RETRIEVE THOSE 15 BOXES FROM
MAR-A-LAGO INITIALLY THIS
JANUARY.
AND THEN IT TOOK A SUBPOENA IN
ORDER TO GET THEM TO TURN OVER
FURTHER CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS TO
FEDERAL INVESTIGATORS WHEN THEY
VISITED MAR-A-LAGO IN JUNE.
SO, THEY'RE REALLY LEANING INTO
THIS POLITICALLY, TRYING TO FIND
A WAY TO SPIN THIS IN A WAY
THAT'S POSITIVE FOR THE FORMER
PRESIDENT WHO HAS SPENT THE PAST
FEW WEEKS SINCE THE SEARCH AT
HIS HOME CLAIMING THAT HE'S
NEVER BEEN IN A BETTER POSITION
FOR 2024, AND THAT REPUBLICAN
ENTHUSIASM IS SURGING AROUND HIM
BECAUSE OF THIS TARGETING.
>> PHIL, THERE ARE OBVIOUSLY
SEVERAL INVESTIGATIONS
SURROUNDING THE FORMER
PRESIDENT.
THIS ONE NOW ABOUT THE RECORDS,
WE DISCUSSED FOR MONTHS THE
JANUARY 6th INVESTIGATION.
YOU SEE THAT THERE IS AN OVERLAP
BETWEEN THE CONCERN OVER THESE
DOCUMENTS AND THE PRESIDENT'S
LIES ABOUT THE 2020 ELECTION.
EXPLAIN THAT.
>> PRETTY SIMPLE.
LET'S GO TO ONE OF THE FACTS WE
SAW TODAY, WHAT WAS IN THE BOXES
WHEN THEY WERE ACQUIRED.
A WHOLE MIX OF MATERIAL
INCLUDING THINGS LIKE NEWS
CLIPS, PRINTOUTS AND TOP-SECRET
INFORMATION.
SO LET'S LOOK AT A STANDARD
TRANSITION OF POWER WHERE YOU
AUTHORIZE THE WHITE HOUSE STAFF
TO CLEAN UP THE WHITE HOUSE SO
THAT YOU CAN ENSURE WHEN YOU
MOVE BACK HOME EVERYTHING IS
TAKEN CARE OF.
THIS PRESIDENT DIDN'T
ACKNOWLEDGE THE LOSS, DIDN'T
CALL TO CONCEDE, DIDN'T HOST JOE
BIDEN AT THE WHITE HOUSE, AND
UNTIL JANUARY, GOING BACK TO THE
JANUARY 6th INSURRECTION,
REFUSED TO ACCEPT THE RESULTS OF
THE ELECTION.
WHAT DOES THAT TELL ME AS A
NATIONAL SECURITY GUY?
WHEN I LOOK AT WHAT'S IN THE
BOXES, CLEARLY PEOPLE IN THE
WHITE HOUSE WERE TOLD DON'T
ACCEPT THE ELECTION AND DON'T
START CLEANING UP THIS PLACE
UNTIL IT'S TOO LATE.
THAT'S WHY WE GET THE CHAOS OF
THESE BOXES THAT ARE STUFFED
WITH ALL KINDS OF CRAP BECAUSE
PEOPLE DIDN'T HAVE TIME TO SORT
IT OUT WHEN THE PRESIDENT SAID
DON'T CLEAN OUT THE WHITE HOUSE,
I STILL BELONG HERE.
I THINK THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED
HERE, VICTOR.
>> KIM, IT'S COME TO LIGHT THAT
ONE OF THE PEOPLE THAT PRESIDENT
TRUMP HAS CONSULTED WITH IN
TERMS OF WHETHER HE SHOULD HAVE
WORKED WITH THE NATIONAL
ARCHIVES TO GIVE BACK ALL OF
THESE CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS WAS A
GUY NAMED TOM FITTON, HEAD OF
JUDICIAL WATCH.
FOR THE PAST COUPLE OF DECADES,
TOM FITTON FILED DOZENS, MAYBE
HUNDREDS OF LAWSUITS.
HE'S A CONSERVATIVE ACTIVIST.
HE SAID IN THE INTEREST OF
GOVERNMENT TRANSPARENCY, HE
FILED THEM AGAINST BILL CLINTON,
HILLARY CLINTON, TRYING TO GET
HIS HANDS ON THEIR DOCUMENTS.
NOW, INTERESTINGLY, WHEN IT
COMES TO DONALD TRUMP, HE IS ALL
FOR SECRECY.
HE THINKS THAT DONALD TRUMP CAN
KEEP THESE -- WHATEVER DOCUMENTS
HE WANTS.
HERE IS TOM FITTON'S LOGIC.
LISTEN TO THIS.
>> IF HE DESIGNATES SOMETHING IS
PERSONAL, HE DOESN'T HAVE TO
TELL ANYONE WHAT HE'S DOING WITH
THEM.
HE CAN TEAR THEM UP.
BUT ONCE THE RECORDS ARE
DESIGNATED AS PRESIDENTIAL,
THAT'S WHEN THIS RESTRICTION
ABOUT DISPOSAL OCCURS.
>> HERE'S MY QUESTION.
IS IT TRUE THAT EVERYTHING A
PRESIDENT TOUCHES FOR FOUR YEARS
BY DEFINITION IS PART OF THE
PRESIDENTIAL RECORDS?
OR DO THEY HAVE SOME PERSONAL
STUFF THAT THEY CAN TAKE WITH
THEM?
>> YOU KNOW, ALISYN, THERE IS A
DISTINCTION UNDER THE
PRESIDENTIAL RECORDS ACT.
JUST TO BE CLEAR, THAT IS
DIFFERENT FROM THESE CRIMINAL
STATUTES WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
THE PRESIDENTIAL RECORDS ACT IS
A POST-WATERGATE REFORM THAT
ESSENTIALLY SAYS OFFICIALLY THAT
OFFICIAL RECORDS BELONG TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, NOT TO THE
INDIVIDUAL THAT IS EXITING THE
WHITE HOUSE.
UNDER THAT STATUTE, SURE, IF
HE'S GOT, YOU KNOW, A HOLIDAY
CARD FROM MELANIA OR A BIRTHDAY
CARD, THAT'S PERSONAL, HE CAN
TAKE THAT.
IT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT UNDER
THE PRESIDENTIAL RECORDS ACT AN
INDIVIDUAL PRESIDENT CAN JUST
DECIDE FOR HIM OR HERSELF,
THERE'S A PROCESS IN PLACE.
FRANKLY, UP UNTIL DONALD TRUMP,
PRESIDENTS RESPECTED THAT.
THEY HONORED THE OFFICE AND THEY
WANTED THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND
HISTORIANS TO HAVE ACCESS TO THE
CRITICAL DOCUMENTS THAT
BASICALLY GIVE A TIMELINE AND
SNAPSHOT OF THE HISTORY OF
AMERICA.
SO, YOU KNOW, THERE'S SO MANY
DISTORTIONS THERE.
THERE'S SO MUCH GASLIGHTING.
THERE'S SO MUCH BAD INFORMATION.
I THINK THE THING TO KEEP IN
MIND, WHEN IT COMES TO THIS
ARGUMENT THAT IT'S POLITICAL, A
FEDERAL JUDGE IS INVOLVED IN
THIS.
FEDERAL JUDGES BY DEFINITION
UNDER THE CONSTITUTION ARE NOT
POLITICAL, THEY'RE THERE FOR
LIFE BECAUSE THE FRAMERS DIDN'T
WANT THEM TO WORRY ABO